- [Instructor] So in this
video we're going to revisit
another super simple economy that only has
a farmer and a builder on an island.
And we're gonna review
what we learned about the
multiplier and the marginal
propensity to consume,
but we're gonna do it a
little bit more abstractly.
So just as a bit of a review,
the marginal propensity
to consume, this is a number
usually between zero and one
that says if you were
to get an extra dollar,
how much of that would you spend?
And so your marginal propensity to consume
if it is 0.25, that means that
if you were to get a dollar
you would spend 25 cents of it.
If your marginal propensity
to consume is 0.6,
that means that if you were to get $1,000,
you would spent six tenths of it,
you would spend $600.
And so using this idea, and I'm gonna keep
it abstract, let's just say that we start
with the farmer, she spends
X dollars on products
or services from the builder.
So X dollars goes to the builder,
now what's the builder going to do?
And we talked about this
in the previous video.
The builder's gonna say, I have X dollars,
we're gonna assume everyone on this island
has the same marginal
propensity to consume,
he's now going to spend some of it.
And he only has one place to spend it,
it's a very simple economy,
what's he going to spend?
Well he's going to spend
X times the marginal
propensity to consume.
If this seems very
abstract, think about it.
If X was $1,000, and if
the marginal propensity
to consume is let's say 25 hundredths,
or 0.25, now he's going to spend $1,000
times 0.25, which would be $250.
But now all of a sudden, the
farmer has this much money,
and what's she going to do?
Well she's going to spend this times
the marginal propensity to consume.
So she is now going to
spend X times the marginal
propensity to consume, which is how much
she got from the builder, and how much of
that is she going to spend?
Well that times the marginal propensity
to consume again.
So it would be the marginal
propensity to consume squared.
And then this just keeps
going on and on and on.
And so he's gonna get this amount,
what's he gonna spend?
Well he's gonna spend
that times the marginal
propensity to consume again,
so it's going to be that,
and we could just keep
going on and on and on,
but if we wanna figure out
how much increased output
is there in this economy
because of that initial
expenditure of X dollars, well you would
just sum everything up.
It would be X plus X times
the marginal propensity
to consume plus X times
to consume squared, goes on and on and on.
If we want, we can factor out an X,
so X times one plus marginal
propensity to consume
plus marginal propensity
to consume squared
on and on and on, and you might recognize
from your algebra class,
or maybe your pre-calculus
class that this is an
infinite geometric series
that we cover in other
videos, and you can actually
sum this up, it's one of the cooler things
in mathematics.
This can be summed up
as being equal to one
over one minus the marginal
propensity to consume.
And so you have that
initial expenditure of X,
but the total amount of output
is X times this expression,
and so that's why this
expression right over here
is known as the multiplier.
If the farmer spent $1
initially on the builder,
well it's going to be $1
times this expression,
in terms of how much
increased output there is
in the simplified economy.
So this is the multiplier.
Now let's do something interesting
and something new that
we hadn't done before.
Let's imagine that somehow
some magic government
shows up on this island and
decides to tax the farmer.
Just says, hey, we're
gonna take some money
from this farmer for whatever it might be,
and so this magic government, the amount
that they take away, we
will call that delta T,
you could sometimes do that
as your change in taxes.
So this is positive, that
means that the government
is getting money, and
money's being taken away
from the farmer.
So what's gonna be, what's
the farmer going to do?
Well, from the farmer's point of view,
they, she now has the
delta T less dollars,
and so that's going to
affect her consumption.
It's going to decrease her consumption.
How much is it going to
decrease her consumption by?
Well it's gonna be the
amount she has to give
to the government, times
her marginal propensity
to consume.
Times the marginal propensity to consume.
Why does this make sense?
Well in the situation where
if I give the farmer a dollar,
let's say the marginal
propensity to consume
is 0.5, if I gave her a dollar,
she would spend 50 cents.
If I took a dollar away from her,
she would spend 50 cents less.
The amount I take away,
times the marginal propensity
to consume.
But if this is the effect on the farmer,
what's going to be the
total effect on output?
Well, this is the situation
where essentially X
is equal to that.
If I take away delta T from the farmer,
that's essentially saying
X is equal to this thing
right over here.
So X is equal to this
thing right over here,
and so what's going to be the impact?
Well, the total output
is going to be equal
to X, which is negative delta T times the
marginal propensity to consume,
that part right over here, that is that,
times this, time the multiplier.
Times one over one minus
the marginal propensity
to consume.
Or if you wanna express this multiplier
as something multiplying
by that increase in taxes,
this would be equal to delta T times
the negative of your marginal
propensity to consume
over one minus the marginal
propensity to consume.
And so this expression,
what seems all fancy
and technical, but all
it's doing is saying,
alright look, if you take
money away from the farmer,
this would be the effect
on her initial spend,
and so then you get this
multiplier on the taxes,
and this negative is because
if you have a positive
taxation right over here, it would have a
decrease in output
because of the multiplier.
And some of you might have seen something
where the denominator looks different,
you might see something called an MPS,
or marginal propensity to save.
And that just comes out of the simple idea
that if I have, let's say
that I have a marginal
propensity to consume of 0.3,
well that means for every dollar I get,
I'm gonna spend 30 cents of it.
Well how much am I going to save?
Well if I spend 30 cents,
I'm gonna save the rest,
so my marginal propensity
to save in this situation
would be 70 cents.
Or another way of thinking about it,
your marginal propensity to consume
plus your marginal propensity to save
is equal to one, or another
way of thinking about it,
subtract the marginal
propensity to consume
from both sides, your
marginal propensity to save
is equal to one minus your
marginal propensity to consume.
And so that's why this
thing is the exact same
thing as this thing, and so sometimes,
you might see a formula
for the tax multiplier,
let me write this down.
Tax multiplier, that looks like this,
where they write the
negative of the marginal
propensity to consume
over, instead of one minus
the marginal propensity to consume,
they write the marginal
propensity to save.
And when you're learning
this in economics,
it all seems so cryptic,
where did this come from,
MPS, MPC, people try to
memorize these things,
but as you can see, it's
coming out of reasonably
straightforward algebra.
Economists sometimes have a knack for
making straightforward
algebra seem a little bit
more complicated than it needs to.
In the next video, I'll
do some worked examples
so that we can actually
apply these formulas
to see, and see that it makes sense.